now your remix of an audience hope you
guys are doing great
I'm real quickly I'm sporting my wild
cat hit her down baby
bear down dip oh I just had a question
for you would you ever consider doing a
fresh banger with our boy - conscious
six nine now that he's out of out of
jail at all
I know Theo would love that I misused
six my fan honestly his music bro he
puts the music out and I wait for it I
even show up at the time yeah if he's
having a histogram live I gotta stop the
car and watch it I mean honestly he's
the first just the fact that he broke
down I mean I just love him just from
being just a [ __ ] biggest punk ass
there is oh she's like I'd love all that
and I love that he hip-hop had this like
kind of it's kind of boring now it's
kind of like there's the older guy oh
they don't go away and they kind of like
talk about the same [ __ ] I think beef
and yeah they're all [ __ ] beefing he
just actually just [ __ ] you yeah [ __ ]
you here's your here's a picture you
being a [ __ ] and like yeah he's not
scared to anybody and I just love that
he just kind of deconstructed
hip-hopping away and people are like no
one can kill him is like impossible I
don't know you came and bothered the guy
I just and he just has all he's like
yeah your side but I'm rainbow hair guy
and you what the [ __ ] were you mad at me
like I mean I just love that he any any
and he didn't have the number one with
that with this for the first thing I to
jail and then he learned how to do it
and he did the you know tied in with the
sales of the clothes and the physical
and just it's all big [ __ ] hack at
this point yeah hacked it and he like he
learned from it and got the number one
and everybody [ __ ] everybody I love the
actual [ __ ] you that everybody that he
did and he came and did it yeah so I
love him and I would I'd love to work in
my nose I know him his his uh his label
head really well we worked on ideas back
before he went to jail and I'm having
connected with him since then but uh how
last I'm not really doing hip-hop right
now but I would do something with him
just cuz I love him as artists yeah and
at this concert for some people buddy
like something that that sucks but I
just I [ __ ] [ __ ] with him hard yeah
yeah not few men are due to dude I'm
like and I love how there's all these
haters that he's II guess it's almost
like this invisible world you know that
he's creating is real renegade about
think it is well even when you said
deconstructed now I'd always heard
people say
i'ma deconstruct something but I never
kind of knew what they were talking
about but just now when you said that
it's there yeah because hip-hop has
these sort of like you think about these
these rules needs a little thing and you
just kind of like embarrassed anybody to
like kind of like people had people
actually don't be for them they're
scared of him now because you can't win
because he'll just do whatever you can't
there's no rules for him you know he's
got and then he gets Nicki Minaj in
which is crazy cuz they're always
fighting over who's Nicki Minaj's
boyfriend but she she was with him on
the record Fifi you back in the day I
think she does also loves his she's very
controversial too you know she'll say
whatever the [ __ ] she wants and I got a
record coming out with her really and
Major Lazer this month and I love her
and I honestly I worked at her a couple
times and she is a [ __ ] hard worker
bro thank you really yeah we're never
really been a fan she as a rapper
lyrically I mean she's like no one's
don't get touch her I feel like and then
at the same time like I we did the song
together and she went back and forth
like I'm just like small song you know
maybe I'll be big she's like like the
record she did it for me and she likes
me I think
but she just went back in the studio
like four times it could I didn't ask
her to say I wanna change this part 1
changes part and she went like a bunch
of times asked me my my advice on it and
um a real pro she's a real collaborator
and she does it like her and Madonna or
two women that were just like they work
harder than me and that's hard I feel
like I worked pretty hard so they both
like good evening good afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was ok but
the next video you can watch could be
way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one